addison ray is
a tick tocker she sleeps over a lot what
room does she sleep in
my mom's addison ray is making her
long-awaited debut
on keeping up with the kardashians life
has changed
so much and by the looks of it addison
is doing what she does
best dance courtney's not really like
this with her other girlfriend
in a preview for next week's keeping up
looks like we'll get a peek into the 41
year old reality star and 20 year old
tick tocker's new found friendship
which blossomed last year amid the
pandemic
i love courtney and chris so much
addison ray is a tick-tocker
she sleeps over a lot what room does she
sleep in my mom's
courtney's not really like this with her
other girlfriend
the pair's bond has grown strong as
we've watched the gal pals having fun
all over social media first they
collabed on a fitness video for push
i start feeling it so much on the fire
hydrants like my side butt is just
burning good thing i did not do butt
yesterday
then they recreated an iconic scene from
keeping up
i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal they even
took a trip together to palm springs
where they had a poolside photo shoot
and filmed what else tick tock videos
[Music]
and now it seems like we'll get to see
even more captured by the kardashians
camera crew
it's a topic et asked addison about in
september
is there a chance that you will appear
on keeping up
with the kardashians um
i don't know who knows what the future
holds so you wouldn't say no if they
were like could we roll the camera
i feel like i'm really not a person to
say no to anything at any time ever
meanwhile on thursday's episode of the
20th and final season of the
long-running reality series
fans caught a rare sighting from 34 year
old rob kardashian
stormy
mom no way you can't bribe kids like yes
i can
mommy has a lollipop for you
no way and despite the sisters best
efforts to force romance between
courtney and scott
i thought this was a family dinner
totally i mean it's still a family
dinner technically
yeah but i think it's pretty obviously
tried to set us up the former couple
who's currently raising their three kids
mason penelope and rayne decided they're
simply better off as platonic co-parents
dinner was very nice but we're just
parents everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
that's how it should be and love is love
and i'm so proud of
them and i'm so proud of them promoting
that it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that both courtney and scott have since
moved on
and they're both off the market scott
made things
instagram official with 19 year old
amelia hamelin in february
while courtney and travis barker went
public with their relationship in
january
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
earlier this month travis opened up
about his longtime
friend turned leading lady and why their
relationship works during an appearance
on the drew barrymore show
i would you know like date girls that
didn't have kids and i find it kind of
hard because they would i think they
would have trouble understanding like
well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me
every night and now
i'm you know spending time with
a woman who's like a great mom who's
like a great friend and i just
you don't have to worry about any of
those things it just comes naturally